Huawei is one of the world's biggest
telecommunications companies and it is a
global leader in 5g technology but it is
also Chinese and therefore in the
opinion of many Western governments it
is inextricably linked to the Chinese
state qua Way has always rejected that
this is au term by the British
government because in January Boris
Johnson agreed that Huawei could have a
limited role on the fringes of Britain's
future 5g network they would be excluded
from critical infrastructure and
military bases though that satisfied
Beijing but annoyed the UK's closest
intelligence partner the United States
Washington believes the Chinese
government will use Huawei to spy on the
West the British intelligence disagreed
GCHQ was confident it could handle it
that's now changed I'm pleased that the
government has recognized on only the
feeling on the back benches which we
touched on before but also the work that
such as my committee of the defence
Select Committee which has said that
this is very dangerous the GCHQ has had
to take stock of the sanctions that have
been posed by the US and that's add an
impact on whether or not while we can
continue in the UK don't forget that
this government had already put a 35
percent cap on Huawei for me the big
decision was how long that they would
remain in the UK as I say it's a
technical as well as political decision
Huawei has spent many years and billions
of dollars developing a 5g network
America hasn't there is no homegrown
u.s. competitor I'm absolutely clear
that we should see the issue of Huawei
in the broader strategic context of the
defining strategic issue of our time
which is the struggle for dominance
between arising China and are gently
declining United States and in
cyberspace
what we're beginning to see as a battle
for the Internet this is about more than
just security
China's secrecy around coronavirus and
the recent illegal security law for Hong
Kong has hardened Britain's approach to
Beijing
this would be the first real example of
that in practice Alistair bungle Sky
News